[Musique]
on est invité chez eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde les gens j'espère
que vous allez bien je vous fais un
petit expérience McDo
vous avez compris le truc je vais tester
parce que j'ai vu des gens le faire mais
je vais tester
je vous montre que le liquide il est
bien ici il arrive bien là oui il y a du
liquide dedans OK
bon j'ai retourné l'écran mais il y a
bien le liquide ok je pose je prends
[Rires]
arnaque du McDo ça c'est la quantité du
Grand vous payez le grand pour avoir un
petit c'est magnifique allez bonne
journée ciao ouais allez grosse arnaques
grosse arnaque
à l'école
il était très fort
[Musique]
mais non tu sais quoi je vais aller voir
ton professeur de judo et je lui mette
une raclée
[Musique]